Jamais fléchis, non jamais
an experienced navigator, disposed to leading any such expedition.
A new spice route.
Yes, sire, as well as the other untold riches of the Indy.
I would like first to hear the opinion of Archbishop Fonseca, head of the Indies Council.
It is always interesting, Your Majesty, to know more about our distant possessions.
But look here, Magellan, how is that as a Portuguese you do not address your sovereign,
my estimable cousin Manuel I?
Who better could finance your project?
Majesty, I serve my country with honor in Africa and the Indies,
but a Moor's arrow in Africa struck.
Now everybody says that I'm good for nothing.
Hmm. What will be the direction that you will take your expedition on?
We'll sail around South America. There's a strait there. It's right there, Your Majesty.
Are you absolutely certain?
I would stake my life on it, Majesty.
I would like to see them.
See them?
My glasses. Of course, here they are.
Looking through these glass pieces, everything's fuzzy. I fail to see how you'll find the passage.
The king is giving a twentieth of all the riches we acquire and five ships.
Do you realize he's giving us five ocean-going ships?
Wait until we see them.
Perhaps I was wrong to dismiss Magellan.
If he finds a passage, it will not be so good for Portugal.
What is to be done?
Just illuminate him.
No, no, no.
But you, Alvarez, go off to Seville and try to stop the expedition.
Don't let it leave.
It won't leave, Your Majesty.
You may be sure of that.
Look, rotten timber every ship.
It will be a year before we leave.
They all have to be repaired.
This is Juan the captain again, your second captain. He'll command the San Antonio.
Here is Quesada. He will command the Concepción.
No doubt a Spaniard.
Yes, as it happens.
Well, it appears it won't be an easy voyage.
And what is your name?
My name is Albo, a pilot and helmsman. I'm Greek captain, sir.
A Greek. Welcome aboard, Albo.
Are you by chance for Captain Ferdinand Magellan, sir?
Yes, I am. What do you want?
It is my understanding that you intend to find a western route to the Indies.
I would like to go along.
And why do you want to come?
It's going to be an extraordinary trip, and I want to note everything down.
This voyage is dangerous, and just where are you from?
Me? I'm Venetian.
I'm Portuguese, commanding a Spanish expedition.
Now, Portugal and Spain are rivals in the spice trade, and Venice as well.
I find it very curious that someone from Venice wants to go on my voyage just for fun.
Naturally, it wouldn't be to discover my secret route to the east.
I don't represent Venice. I am Antonio Pigafetta, a Venetian gentleman, a knight of roads.
I just want to chronicle the story of your trip. I will pay my way if you like.
Very well, Antonio. But remember, nobody is certain of returning alive.
My servant here will show you to your quarters.
Hey, Fernando! I'm unable to depart on this expedition, and neither can you, I fear.
And why is that, my friend? Why not?
It's my horoscope. It says that I won't survive the journey. And as for you, it's the same thing. You won't live. We'll just have to call it off.
We can't fight our destiny. I will be terribly unhappy taking the voyage without you.
The flotilla will follow me at all times, gentlemen. At night, a fire will burn. You are not to lose contact with my ship.
Two fires if I change course, three for dropping sails, understand? Those are my orders.
And what will our course be exactly, Captain?
The Canary Islands. I'll give you additional orders as required. That'll be all.
Well, we shall see.
Captain, aren't we headed for the Indies by sailing west?
West would be that direction toward the setting sun, but we're headed in a southerly direction, Captain!
Yes, Antonio, you're right. The ship is on a southerly course, but I wouldn't worry, we're on the right one.
You're sure this way we'll reach the Indies?
You can't be sure of anything in this life.
Follow Magellan's signal flame orders of our commander, until further orders, hmm.
First, fail!
We're sailing west! You very nearly put us all under water!
I've no need to justify my orders. I command this flotilla in the name of the King of Spain.
You did, but now I'm commanding Magellan.
Castagena, you are under arrest.
Put him in irons!
Put Magellan in irons, that's the arrangement!
Mutiny is punishable by death hanging!
Just a little mistake, Admiral, I assure you.
In the hold with the prisoner. Obey my order.
And as for you, watch your step. I won't be so lenient next time.
Now go back to your ships and follow until further orders.
Southwest, we'll be able to take on supplies at last, just in time.
Playing fish!
No, but move ahead!
No, not all that.
And we're in the Southern Hemisphere. Winter starts!
I think that we'd better await spring here, Antonio.
The ships will be sheltered during the winter.
We're not far from the Antarctic.
This is a good place for us to stay and wait for warmer weather.
We've no choice.
But it means staying here for weeks, even months!
Yes, three or four months.
What the hell?!
Somebody wants to return to Spain!
Nobody believes in your impossible secret passage now!
I don't care, that's an order and you will obey.
Quesada, you watch your step.
We're going to mutiny, we'll take the San Antonio first and we'll get rid of that Portuguese noose, sir.
Mosquito, you're under arrest!
Stop!
For mutiny, you'll find out who lives in noose.
We're going to mutiny Spanish, he'll be with us.
We can count on him.
Ready, ready, ready.
Shhh.
We'll eat them.
Make a move, what about it, Mendoza, are you with us?
Chase, I'll get my sword, won't be a minute.
What's happened, Cartagena? Does it mean you've just been released?
Yeah, I'm taking command of our expedition, finally.
I'm Magellan.
That's enough talk!
Oh.
What is it, Antonio? You run as if the devils were at your heel.
Captain, it's a mutiny. They've liberated Cartagena and have commandeered three ships.
Scoggles!
I'll hang them!
Sada says he wants to negotiate. Fine.
He may come aboard.
He agrees. He will speak to you aboard his ship.
I smell a rat. I will see him in a neutral rowboat.
Go on.
They're on their way here. When their boat draws alongside our ship, they won't be seen on the San Antonio.
Quickly, put 24 sailors in a rowboat. Now!
Sailors back on the Victoria. All right, what's Magellan's in?
Possession of three ships. We can block the entrance.
Sir, but I couldn't.
One less.
Now we've one more to recover.
That ship.
Can I can't?
The mutineers will be tried tomorrow.
Sara, you instigated a mutiny, and you killed an officer of his majesty. Do you admit to this?
Yeah.
You, Contagina, were one of the leaders in the mutiny?
Yes, but I surrendered, and I never killed anyone at all.
As for you others, you are weak men.
You were led into rebellion.
Kasada, you murdered, and you must be given your punishment, sentenced to decapitation.
You, Cartagena, you stood a mutiny.
Every navy in the world punishes mutineers with a sentence of...
But fortunately, you refrain from killing.
Therefore, your life will be spared. You will remain in this land.
The rest will be hanged, and may God have mercy.
To all of you, I grant a pardon. All of you will be needed when we sail again.
And you have Magellan to thank for preserving your life.
If it's Santiago and carry out a reconnaissance mission to the south, we will wait for you here.
It's two weeks now, they've been gone.
We can't abandon Hope.
What's all this?
They're back!
You've returned safe.
But the Santiago has been sunk, a sudden storm, and she foundered.
But you are alive, that's the most important thing, because you all returned.
All right, let's go!
Find bottom!
A splendid sign, it means it's most likely a strait.
I know it's right here, I'm sure.
Take the Conception.
you and the san antonio will sail on reconnaissance there's a passage we'll follow you in aye aye captain
passage second course west southwest that's it they've entered the passage yes i was absolutely
fabulous captain but you were sure of the passage right you knew it all the time my young friend
nothing is ever certain but i am sure of that passage forward take the southwest branch and the
the Victoria will follow. You, Serao, will take the southeast branch with the San Antonio.
Where is the San Antonio?
The planet Gomez put Captain Serao in irons. I believe he sailed back to Spain, but I can't...
That's terrible, because it was transporting almost all of our provisions.
Today is Wednesday, the 28th of November, 1520. We have sailed through the Straits and are
entering another ocean. It is very peaceful. Magellan named it the Pacific.
Well, Antonio, I trust you've put down everything. You should write, it's the first time ships
have navigated from the Atlantic Ocean into the Pacific Ocean.
Yes, Captain.
How much further do we have to sail before we reach the Indies?
The astronomer said 1,000 miles, but, um...
But?
But I believe it's more like thousands.
Magellan was right.
He sailed some 12,000 miles.
One of the most arduous voyages ever undertaken.
A month and a half since the passage and still no land in sight.
Antonio, we must have covered more than 3,000 miles.
The astronomer was mistaken.
They're all wrong.
Even the maps are wrong. We're running low on drinking water and food. We'll have to begin rationing everything.
Three months with no fresh food and almost no water, and what we do get is yellow and brackish.
We are surviving on old insect-infested rat-fowl biscuit crumbs.
Sometimes there are odd bits of oxhide that had protected the main yard arm.
The men are holding up as well as they can. Nobody talks about it, but we're all wondering if this is the end.
God rest his immortal soul.
Over a hundred days.
Oh, I know when will it ever end.
Magellan just missed the Marquisa Islands and Tahiti,
where abundant truth would have saved all of his men from scurvy.
At last, he reached the island of Guam,
in the Marianas Archipelago.
They're welcome.
Taking off with it as well!
This is an island of thieves!
It's finally filled up.
Can't be the Moluccas.
We're too far north.
We'll stop here and rest.
And we'll take on provisions.
Come and see!
Oh, come and see what I found!
What do you want?
Says the chief invites us to his village.
Yes, with pleasure.
We too greet him.
I'm glad you understand their language.
Yes, it reminds me of my native tongue.
That's right, your home isn't very far away.
And that means that you're the first man ever to go around the world.
His nephew wanted to be baptized to show that they are friends.
Go tell Padre.
I baptize you Charles New Ferdinand in the name of...
I message for you, from Charles and Ferdinand.
Who are they?
You know, sir, the chief and his nephew.
Oh yes, and what exactly do they want?
They're Christians that you're their brother, and it is your duty to defeat their, uh...
Yes, defeat who?
Lapu-Lapu-Lapu.
No one say that we're here in peace.
If you don't come, Captain, they'll think you're scared.
All right, I'll come.
No, Captain, you mustn't go. It'll be much too dangerous. Your life is...
Confieve their conversion was to trap us.
If my men go into battle, then I will lead them.
Ask your life, Captain. We need you.
I won't. Don't worry, Antonio.
This day, the 27th of April, 1521, in the Philippines, Ferdinand Magellan,
after discovering the sea passage between the Atlantic and Pacific, died.
Our guiding light is extinguished.
He didn't go around the world, did he?
Well, he had been in India long before this voyage,
so Magellan did go around the world.
But what he demonstrated was that you can sail around South America's southern coast.
Did Magellan's ships ever go back? Did they return to Spain?
Of the five ships that had left, only one returned home.
Just one?
Yeah, that's right. And of the 218 sailors, only 18 returned.
We now have three ships, and only a hundred men.
Undermanned, the ships can't operate.
We'll have to abandon one of them.
You're right. We'll abandon the Concepcion. She's in bad condition, anyway.
And so they burned the Concepcion, the Trinidad, and the Victoria Sailor.
Finally, the Molucca Islands! They're called the Spice Islands.
We can just put in and see what they're like.
Saffron Clothes! Look at all of them!
Cinnamon and red pepper.
They're worth a fortune.
You like?
I'd rather we sail around the tip of Africa. It's much shorter.
Yes, it's a shorter route. However, we could run into the Portuguese.
He's right. I would prefer the Pacific route. With the Trinidad, it's much safer.
That way is much too long.
Well, the Victoria and the Trinidad were never to return.
After six months of hard sailing, the Victoria finally returned to Seville.
But the ship and men were in a sorry state.
Just think, 18 survivors.
And when they set out, they had been more than 200 on five ships.
So, all these spices are for approximately 10,000 times their cost.
My congratulations, you're entitled to your full shares.
But first, we must deduct the amount we paid for the spices,
your provisions, and naturally the price of the four ships that were lost.
And you will agree that Victoria is in terrible condition,
really a write-off for us, so we deduct its value from the profits.
Now we must deduct four-fifths of the total sum, which belongs to the king.
And the rest you can share between you.
Hello, my friends.
With this money, I invite you to the best dinner that any of us has had since...
since exactly how many days were we away in all, Antonio?
It was more than a thousand days.
Oh, the best meal we've had in one thousand days.
And then what?
Well, then I go back to sea again.
The sharks are much less dangerous than the ones you find on shore.
And what will you do, Elcano?
The same. I can't bear being ashore any longer.
But you, Antonio, you are forbidden to go on any ship.
You stay and write the history of our voyage.
The story of Magellan, who has done what nobody else had.
They sailed around the world.
It's our story, too. Don't forget to mention us.
It was truly an adventure. An almost unbelievable trip.
And without the heroism of one visionary, Ferdinand Magellan,
it wouldn't have been done.
It is unlikely that anyone will ever sail such a voyage again.